[Musique]
toujours passé raymond et déjà du mal à
ce petit poulet ouais bon soir alors bon
soir
l'histoire il s'agit d'une recette se
trouve ce mélange qui aurait une recette
presque exhaustive à l'amt révèle votre
poulet tonnes pour les free au banal
c'est aussi je vous demande de garder
ses bananes pendant lequel je me demande
combien ou marc andré 4 tout à l'heure
ah oui je souffre le poulet d'abord en
quatre morceaux
voyez-vous d'abord j'enlève les crises
comme ceci dit alors on va me reprocher
de repos un grand couteau l'enfant d'un
plus petit poste mais quelquefois les
téléspectateurs dia nous avons nous
n'avons pas un aussi gros qu'un oui mais
c'est lorsque c'est une valeur sûre on
voit bien ce que je vais couper mais
vous mettriez d'abbott même pas alors là
moi je vous reprocherai le coq aux
femmes et la main oui si on voit la fois
comme ça sur le bréchet c'est sur le
brochet jusqu'au bord et chez paul l
anatomie gallinacés vous l'êtes
extrêmement familier n'a pas de secret
pour vous et aulas je vais relever
ainsi pour l aile entière
j'aime bien employer des termes que je
comprends pas tout voilà ici également
le second set ceci je présente très vite
puisque n'auront pas beaucoup de temps
alors nous va le rester la carcasse nous
la conserverons bien sûr parce que ça on
peut feront enfin un bon bouillon demain
matin ce soir avec cette carcasse alors
je m'en vais également désossé ici la
cuisse et voilà c'est très simple nous
suivons l'os lorsque l'on est apparu
bien on fait le tour de la jointure
il reprend l'os à nouveau sa longueur
voyez alors voilà non c'est beau surtout
pour savoir là c'est non pas là alors
non je n'ai pas enlevé parce que ce
serait trop long à désosser
mais si j'avais eu le temps de le
désosser je l'aurais fait alors ici ou
alors faisons pareil au mans on arrive
sur la jointure allant faire un tour
et puis on reprend sur la longueur
d'ailleurs le look de l'os et voilà les
deux cuisses de poulet sont désossés c
ur les débarrasser pas tremblé c'est ça
oui c'était l'emploi ça tremble carcasse
alors là j'avais coupé en huit morceaux
ou en poulet que c'est un tout petit
poulet est un poulet de 900 grammes eh
bien il peut aller facilement pourquoi
personne parce que vous allez voir que
nous allons lui donner du volume en
quelques leçons différentes entre la
cuisse se réduit donc à l'aller on
appelle ça des pays en appel ce site le
noir de poules elles aussi si toi tu
voulais faire attention les gestes ça
fait beaucoup mais on pêche avec un
couteau et on peut le faire avec le
plaza brousseau il veut le fer avec une
partie
alors nous allons le faire perdre foi a
pris fin quatre fois oui quatre fois
pour le pour les cuisses et quatre fois
pour les iem
c'est une multiplication c'est toujours
très difficile de faire ça très vite
comme ça compliqué voilà alors je m'en
vais mettre les huit morceaux côte à
côte
ici et les assaisonner comme ça je le
vois bien un exploit assez facile pour
moi de bien les assaisonner
alors d'abord le sait ils ont les
retourner si tu ne cesses encore avait
déjà montré
oui je rentre du poivre chaque morceau
on peut chercher un morceau retourner
indiqué il va faire la future île
catherine cette free ou les français oui
oui c'est une annonce est une recette
française
c'est une recette à faire j'allais dire
lui avait glané dans un pays où vous
êtes en ce moment oui c'est en ce moment
il fait cette émission nous donne
l'occasion de dire qu'en ce moment même
en hiver n'est pas là je suis en
louisiane aujourd'hui la date où passera
cette émission vraiment l'hiver sera
nouvelle orléans est en santé alors ici
voyez-vous fariné et puis mis dans le
jaune d'oeuf et en langue anglaise
s'appelle une anglaise ceci c'est de
l'oeuf battu savais pas que j'en ai
blanc apparaît comme peu d'eau un peu
d'huile et du sel et du poivre également
on peut l'assaisonner un petit peu non
je crois que georges blanc un petit peu
d'eau salée quoi nous allons revenir sur
la suite revenir ici parce que ça colle
un petit peu ça ça devient onctueuse
ça donne une certaine maturité au vo ça
fait exactement ce qu'on appelle une
émulsion
alors voyez vous je vais retourner
maintenant dans la vie maintenant dans
l'âme il craint la troisième opération
première la farine deuxième l'anglais
troisième vingt mille huit morceaux bien
la platine et ça va faciliter la nation
historiens par personne 2 pas perso je
dis je vous dis c'est un petit poulet
mais néanmoins il est nécessaire de
prévoir un petit poulet comme ça de 800
grammes environ
pour 4 personnes
les escales
on fait déjà de cette opération je suis
très fier vous montre ma science de
temps en temps pour vous montrer que
j'adore ça c'est terminé
je voudrais m'en débarrasser elle aurait
besoin d'ailleurs tout à l'heure je vous
le redémarrer alors là quelques secondes
d'ailleurs j'ai oublié que j'en avais
besoin d'un nouveau alors je vais
d'abord finir je me suis dit non non non
je peux le dire quand je revis ceci est
largement dans cette mi-temps vous voyez
je parle très largement
et puis je vais remettre ici sur la
planche pour que la panure pénètre bien
soit bien bien terminé c'est important
et au delà alors qu une spatule ou avec
le plat d'un couteau chacun séparément
alors les quadrilles et quelquefois
comme ça oui oui c'est joli mais je sais
pas nécessaire oui je crois qu'on peut
découler un petit coup de quadrille le
retrouvons d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
c'est la vie l'effet s'est pas seulement
pour la cuisine ça sera pour le service
que ses geôliers
voilà une recette qui se fait facilement
les mises à jour alors elle est à
chauffer et nous allons prouver quelque
chose
on va voir on va faire un test vous
faire voir comment on se rend compte
d'abord l'avait un peu mes doigts vous
allez nous montrer comment on peut voir
si la friture et chaud 17,1 on sait
jamais si elle est trop pas assez
oui alors vous allez voir nous allons
faire si le 90 est très facile de savoir
via un test qui d'ailleurs consiste à
faire ceci alors dicté à faire ceci on
pourra une goutte d'eau comparée
cependant affecté alors on voit comment
l'eau réagi oui alors il ya un
entraîneur préfère et celui de prendre
une
dans lequel il a commencé déjà mais vous
là on voit que les choses puisque ça
commence à frire mesan éclabousse pas
l'autre système et de jeter un peu d'eau
quant à une gouttelette d'eau ses thèmes
et ses bons débuts difficiles dans les
glaces randonnée vient de compte on sent
très bien compris où on sait que la
friture et geof elle me paraît
extrêmement favorable
alors maintenant nous allons passer sur
un peu plus violents à faire sur une
source de chaleur plus fort que ça aille
plus vite pendant l'essai ça et nous
allons mettre le poulet à cuire un sport
dans cette friture façon que nous
roulons de paris bien sûr à l'au-delà
volume morceaux nous allons le mettre à
tâcher de retrouver vite
oui c'est arrivé une fois il nous a
manqué une cuisse de poulet et c'est
pour info les remettra il suffit de ses
cuirs cela alors voudrions voir la
gentillesse de rapporter je vous prie
des deux plats les parents d'abord et
ensuite les deux plats que je vous avais
confié tout à l'heure oui 60 paraît
alors ici lui réponde quatre bananes que
voilà je surveille de ce coin de l'oeil
oui catherine vous voulez vous on va les
remettre comme il était tout à l'heure
non ça ira très bien
alors non non c'est pas la pression je
vais revenir dans les mêmes conditions à
peu près alors j'appelle les bananes
tout bêtement
non je sais que ça se fait
on fait des tâches urgentes et
d'ailleurs
alors oui banane encore coban a vu que
l'on pense pas trop mais pas tout à fait
assez mûr pour la consommation vous
allez voir leur faire subir une petite
réparation
d'ailleurs l'opération pendant ce temps
l'autre pour l'équipe pendant un certain
temps dans l'afrique alors si je vois
qui va trop vite j'ai à côté une une
plaque et moins chaudes les joueurs le
changer alors ici voyez où chaque banane
je vais là ciselé comme ceux-ci l'incisé
très légèrement tous les assises et des
ciseaux ou comme ceux ci ont pénétré la
friture également l'assaisonnement car
elles vont être assaisonnée il s'agit
des légumes et non pas de fruits avec la
planète aussi bien en légumes fruits et
si nous le considérons surtout comme un
fruit
mais dans les pays d'origine sur toi en
pacifique sud où il y en a énormément
c'est surtout l'image est avec novitec
jamais oui ça c'était une autre fois
c'est ici en louisiane alors ça l'est
c'est exactement comme ça on fait tout à
l'heure pour le poulet est passé d'abord
à la farine alors ici ça va en premier
comment remettre sur moi un chiffre plus
voilà donc la cuise vous allez reprendre
je suis alors je ressens les trois
opérations par besoin de les habiliter
si longtemps farine
mélangez celle où s'affairent à ce
moment là je suis seul anglais n'est ce
pas alors là il faut l'assister un peu
souffert voilà bien longtemps je me suis
fait remarquer que vous essayer de leur
donner une forme
oui j'ai les redresse et redresse et ce
sommet théorisée par les petites
coupures
j'allais redresse et en même temps ça me
permet de mieux les pannes et salir de
mieux faire pénétrer
alors ici voyez-vous d'un médecin alors
cette fois ci on peut se débarrasser si
vous la voile à l'envié de me
débarrasser des deux et puis nous allons
remettre à nouveau la friture plus
chaudes
on peut d'abord mettre les bananes de
temps nous allons renforcer à nouveau
simultanément je l'aimais un oui oui oui
je l'aimé simultanément bien que je les
retiens oui mais tous maintenant on va
faire même un petit ménage
oui mais dans des titres alors
maintenant nous allons voir ça va être
très simple
alors là nous forçons à nouveau la
chaleur et puis nous allons venir ici
avec des pommes soufflées et alors
voulez vous me donnez je vous prie le
grand plat là bas sur lequel il y entre
à pied voisins pour les ouvriers non là
on papier mais c'était une sortie c'est
leur chance à moi c'est exact et précis
dans la vie quand il s'agit d'un temps
chaud ce n'est pas un parti l on la sent
pas les tensions qui ça elle a retiré le
poulet cuit très haut il flotte
d'ailleurs
et quand en principe vous voulez qu'ils
fabriquent un poulet qui flotte dans la
peinture est cuit il est cuit ou ça
serait du canard le voyons douter mais
le poulain
nous sommes sûrs alors essayé de compter
les morceaux à ce qu'ils étaient cela
paraît presque un peu clairs parfois
avec les airs oui ça paraît que j'aurais
cru j'aurais surtout c'est sûr du
contraire
voilà alors laissez cuire cette banale
par la paire de seconde vous mettez au
chaud relevé au chaud le tient au chaud
sans trop cassé et puis et où je fais le
maximum de chaleur ici oui ça marche
mais oui c'est assez gros alors
évidemment ça ça va nous demander
quelque peu tout je pense de prison mais
enfin une phase à paulhan laissons le
faire si vous voulez les héros soit là
c'est ça quand le zéro soit là alors
voyez je laisse faire ça alors le podium
de parler si vous voulez du poulain en
peu de temps la façon de couper le
poulet
ce sont des pommes de terre souffler
mais qui ont des gars se fait une fois
et bien le vent nous servir de décor non
ça ne fait pas partie de la recette
c'est celui comment pour donner un petit
coup d'oeil à
un petit coup d'oeil gentil mais en
réalité c'est pas utile alors vous avez
vu comment nous allons couper le poulet
je pouvais décomposer si vous voulez le
mouvement d'une façon beaucoup plus
lente de façon à ce que l'on voit mieux
alors voyez où ici pour enlever la
cuisse
on a présenté le couteau à la naissance
de la crise comme ceux ci
et puis on coupe et ou en tournant et
lorsque ces coupes et on repousse la
crise jusqu'à l'os à ce moment-là l'os
cède à la jointure on introduit le
couteau dans la jointure très peu et on
en arrache f1 et au panama et l'instinct
vous avez vous avez deux minutes de
tranquillité c'est pour découvrir me
c'est tout petit
non non je t'assure que c'était ici
c'était une boîte est nécessaire de
surveiller bana vous auriez pu faire
c'est parfois une sauce n'importe quoi
mais non alors ils ces chirurgiens
manquait alors ici voyez-vous la
jointure de l'ale se trouve juste en
haut
voyez vous dis c'est ici un renflement
bien le renflement c'est la loi alors
voyez où l'incendié le couteau dedans a
eu exactement lentement vous avez
exactement dans la joie alors on fait
tourner le couteau comme ceux ci on
arrache également on arrache de la même
façon que se crée alors un suprême
ensuite je voulais pouvons faire voir
puisque en quelques secondes
comment faire autrement on fait en moins
chaud et comment vous faites vous 4 et
pour faire de jolies petites papillotes
et seulement ce que personne n'avait
fait n'avait remarqué c'est que vous
aviez fait cinq ans et rien et ça c'est
ça que vous sauvez corps du mans cup un
atelier 5 ans et que vous aussi vous
annonce que vous voulez avec et non pas
du tout je n'ai pas pensé surtout des
jeunes
pour les 4 pas du tout l'air c'est ça je
sais moi qu'un vernis qu'avait dit au
lieu de dire préparer pour chaque membre
du poulet avait dit pour chaque patte
alors voici comment on dégage l'os et
après on fait rentrer la chair à
l'intérieur c'est face aux que lorsque
sa cuisine sans dégâts elle proteste
c'est bien bravo voyez-vous quand elles
vont remonter à la surface
je sais qu'ils aillent sera comme pour
le full et ça c'est bon on va remettre
alors oui et en cuisant lorsqu'on a eu
la précaution de rentrer les chers
toutous tout ça se dégage en puisant la
rétraction là qu'ils sont et que l'offre
légale est très jolie
nous avons réussi et se terminer nous
allons remettre mais c'est sur la figure
et vous occultez les batailles
maintenant sont alors seconde opération
[Applaudissements]
mario est longé la flotte conception et
de son free allait au centre bell dont
complet d'ailleurs présents samedi à
dakar comme et tout ça toujours ça là
bas
et puis je m'en vais faire souffler ses
quelques pommes
ici tu vois monsieur rire de découvrir
frais une fois la recette est bonne
santé je voulais en fait je vous le
promets je vous dis ça parce que vous
savez que nous avons des amis à bordeaux
maintenant à qui vous devez savoir à
quel rythme et noir n'ont pas pourquoi
on n'est pas très amusante mais moi
quand aurons nous enfin il y avait donné
lieu à des polémiques
bon eh bien oui ou c'est non sucré le
premier emploi oui mais leur souffle
m'excuserai non je vous ai pas vu les
faire souffert mais voyez où est leur
souffle quand même très bien la seconde
l1 l'an aucune comment dirais-je aucune
rancoeur montre moi non plus je vous
serai petit four connaissance et ça
c'est bien nous allons envoyer
elles vont être prêts nous allons
également opérer comme nous venons de
faire c'est à dire dans les mettre à
côté sur la petite sur le petit plat
avec le torchon présence culturelle
bouddhique
alors il faut les laisser assez assez
cuir pour qu'il ne retombe pas le
remuant l'autre non lassana plus nous
aider ça n'a plus rien dire est que ça
aurait en premier lieu c'est à dire la
première cuisson vous avec en premier un
tricks en effet le remuer tout le temps
là n'ont rien je rappelle que pour faire
des pommes soufflées
il faut mettre à peu près sept candidats
chaque fois c'est à dire une vingtaine
dans la friture que cette friture 60 35
degrés qu'elles soient remuer tout le
temps pendant la première cuisson et que
dès que la première commence à souffler
on les charge friture on le met dans une
voiture plus chaudes
c'est à dire environ 150 et à ce moment
là elle souffle et quand elles ont
soufflé une fois c'est ce que vous avez
vu c'était l'époque que j'ai vu tout à
l'heure elle avait soufflé le point de
les retirer et
attendu d'avoir besoin d'un suivi alors
soyez réserve une petite surprise tout à
l'heure dès maintenant appeler la
recette non je voudrais finir si vous
cherchez je crois que non je vais vous
demander de seconde de plus ou moins de
ce qu'on ne puisse pas longtemps non
c'est pas tout à fait terminé enfin
c'est pas loin
savez vous laissez pas vous avez mis un
torchon là alors attention
s'ils persistent voilà eh bien c'était
un mini londres et c'est le plat est
aussitôt dressé le chaland à mener si
vous voulez la petite nature morte est
prête
alors nous allons dresser ce poulet
puisqu'il s'agit d'un tirage alors nous
allons mettre d'abord les morceaux de
poulet pendant ses shows
enfin je supporte a dit il avec un air
très dégagée et en se brûlant biens
authentiques
oui mais je ne l'avais jamais voilà
c'est l'école explique theft stoïcisme
marque créée mais s'il vous plaît de
mettre les bananes en retour
voyez il ya il y a une technique du
dressage en quelque sorte alors c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait rare celle là
voyage
celle là elle avait l'air de ne pas
vouloir écrire et compter
[Musique]